parmi toutes les marques de pc il y en a
qui sortent un peu du lot il y en a qui
sortent pas du lot qui sont bien qu'ils
sont pas géniales gros éventail ça vous
le savez vous à prendre seulement rien
mais les marques découle que j'aime bien
que je vous ai déjà présenté plusieurs
fois c'est d'elle je voulais déjà
présenté il ya un produit que j'aime
beaucoup qui ressort un peu du lot pour
moi c'est toute la gamme xps vous a
présenté le xps 13 de cette année il n'y
a pas très longtemps et maintenant place
à l'ex ps 15 qui est là qui est beau qui
est choqué très sain parc à flins belle
qualité qui a aussi quelques points qui
pourraient être améliorés c'est plutôt
normal toute façon tous les produits
peuvent à un moment ou à un autre être
améliorés dell ne fait pas exception je
vous parle de ce texte ps 15 de dell
vous dites ou s'il est bien oui donc en
commun qu'est ce qui se passe maintenant
[Musique]
avant toute chose en préambule je vous
inviter à les découvrir un pote à moi
arnaud qui a lancé sa chaîne de teck qui
a juste de démarrer et qui a justement
testé ce petit produit dont je vous ai
mis un lien en bas dans la description
des habitats et découvert sa chaîne
c'est vachement sympa leur art ne sais
pas s'il vous souviendrez on a déjà pas
mal collaborent ensemble il est venu on
a parlé de casques de verre ensemble on
a fait pas mal de trucs donc ça mais
qu'une expertise beaucoup kévin parce
que c'est un gamer créé longtemps
s'intéresse beaucoup aux pc montage
démontage qui est une vraie expertise
steak est ce intéressant donc aller
jeter un coup d'oeil à sa chaîne elle se
lance c'est le début c'est nouveau c'est
rigolo faut le soutenir
n'hésitez pas à aller le voir vous
abonnez vous mettez des poutres sur tout
ça tout ça et puis vous des tuques
augmenté à voir maintenant place à ce
produit
le dell xps le mec qui bug dell xps 15
pouces c'est j'aime beaucoup alors il ya
plein plein plein plein plein de choses
à dire sur ce produit
ce qu'il faut savoir déjà grosso modo
sur ce produit c'est que c'est un
produit qui est destiné je dirais plutôt
bureautique montage vidéo édition de
photos ce n'est pas un ordinateur de
gaming ont peu joué avec mais pour moi
si vous voulez acheter un ordinateur et
que vous êtes un gamer c'est pas
forcément là dessus qu'il va falloir
aller bien vous puissiez le faire mais
bon voilà c'est un petit peu limité à
l'est sur un vrai pc gaming si c'est le
cas notamment alienware du côté de chez
dell parce que s'ils ont des productions
vraiment très sympa et pour le coup
gaming est d'ailleurs s'ils voulaient
faire du gaming avec des lits aussi des
produits des lignes ennemies qui sont
vraiment cool
j'en ai déjà présenté il ya pas très
longtemps donc ça il faut le savoir faut
situer produisent c'est un produit qui
est tous là en terme de tarifs qui part
de près 1500 euros jusqu'à quasiment
3000 euros il y a un potentiel de choix
que ce soit au niveau de l'écran pas
voir son écran led soit un écran lcd ça
c'est à vous de voir une de libé est ce
soit vous pouvez bien évidemment choisir
votre âme me giga de ram 16 32 c'est
possible le stockage également toujours
du ssd 512 interart 2 tera à vous de
voir
il ya pas mal de petites configurations
possibles tout ça forcément va fumer sur
le prix pareil au niveau de la
performance
intel core i5 i7 9 2 9e
génération et même au niveau de la carte
graphique de base la config la plus
basse depuis une intel graphique usd 630
et après des vous voulez arrive au
dessus vous avez une nvidia geforce gtx
1650 avec 4 gigas de ram dédiée et gddr5
donc tout ça ça vous permet de choisir
et forcément ça va influer sur le prix
ça c'est un peu là qu'on fait que pouvez
venir vous moudre un peu tous les côtés
d'ailleurs si vous intéresse demi un
lien maddin description maintenant on va
partir ce côté un petit peu générique de
la chose parler du design par l'écran
voir s'il est intéressant et quels sont
ses points forts et quels sont ses
points faibles
la toute première chose c'est la partie
si le design alors bon c'est assez
standard c'est assez classique on
retrouve bien évidemment sur le logo
d'elle
ça c'est bien c'est un ordi qui
forcément quand on est sur ducasse
poussera un peu plus large mais il n'y a
rien de bien grave si moins d'un kilo
lui donc il reste quand même assez
correcte en termes de poids le truc que
c'était un peu regretter c'est le 2 ou
le design on sait pas bien bien grave
s'est passée sans vous ne la voyez pas
c'est pas ce qui va être le mien si vous
comparez par rapport à un macbook pro
est immense et les finitions sont pas
extraordinaires
au-delà de ça s'est posé en dessous ça
marche pas grave bonbons de ce point de
vue là c'est pas très grave si sorte de
trouver des petites choses à dire là
dessus on a un châssis qui est
entièrement en aluminium donc ça c'est
vraiment hyper cool vous avez tous
définition fibre carbone là qui sont
extrêmement jolie
on a vraiment quelque chose de très très
qualitative carbone c'est vraiment très
sympa vous avez en plus ici un petit
bouton pour la lui mais ça c'est plutôt
normal il faut galets lui met en avant
une autre mais en plus il fait office de
capteur d'empreintes digitales pour nous
la vidéo est plutôt bien que demande le
peuple
donc c'est vrai qu'on a un produit qui
est sympa un beau design assez léger et
surtout je trouve assez compact et c'est
vraiment le point intéressant de ce
produit là c'est que vous le permet très
facilement vous l'emmener partout avec
vous en gros vous avez presque un
châssis de 14 pouces quelque chose près
et pourtant c'est bien un 15,6 pouces de
diagonale donc ça c'est top
et bien justement parlons-en de cet
écran pour moi c'est un des points forts
des points plus important mais attention
c'est à dire que là vous avez un écran
de 15,6 pouces de diagonale non je ne
fais pas le cash de bryce c'est bien la
diagonale de l'écran vous avez là dessus
qu une résolution sur celui qui gèle à
1,3840 par 2167 lui adresse la 4k uhd
jeanne écran oled
donc on a vraiment un truc qui est
vraiment pas pour moi c'est ce qui est
mieux là sur cet écran oled vous avez
des noirs et des contrastes profonds les
noirs infinie vous avez des couleurs qui
sont vraiment belles se donne vraiment
envie lorsque vous regardez des films
des séries
vous êtes vraiment dans un truc hyper il
jean c'est beau c'est hyper créatif
c'est très précis les couleurs sont
superbes
l'écran est lumineux d'elle nous annonce
400 dit ça marche c'est bien de ce point
de vue là y'a pas souci en plus d'aller
la techno del cinema donc c'est vrai
qu'on a vraiment un très bel écran mais
attention parce que l'écran oled est
proposé uniquement en option alors
franchement je peux pour moi l'intérêt
de ce produit là si vous voulez sur le
xps 15 pouces de 2019
c'est de prendre l'écran oled mais
lorsque vous regardez la config de base
vous verrez qu'il ya bien deux
possibilités
si vous regardez les configs de départ
vous allez avoir un écran ip sc du lcd
vous n'aurez en tactile soit c'est
vachement cool mais si vous voulez le
hall elle tout de suite le prix
franchement montée mais bon après
pourquoi pas cet investissement aussi et
vous n'aurez pas le tactile alors bon
voila c est le choix à faire qu'est ce
que vous voulez vous est ce que vous
voulez du tactile à côté de ça la dalle
ip slcd marche bien les maîtriser elle
est très belle donc le dessus c'est
pareil il absolument pas tous il si vous
voulez aller plus loin et surtout avoir
c'est noir a fini ce contraste ses
couleurs y perdit des hypers qui allient
l'oled est juste incroyable
faites bien attention lors de votre
choix pas parce que vous allez sur le
dell xps 15 2019 que vous allez avoir un
écran led ça il faut le savoir
le duo est pas mal il ya assez de
puissance alors à prix ronds ça nous
fait quelque chose que voulant faire
vous avez des petits haut parleurs qui
sont situés juste en dessous de chaque
côté le font bien normal c'est à ces
qualifs il avoir un côté un peu médium
on reste sur un ordinateur ça marche
c'est pas son point fort mais ça marche
sur cette partie là on a deux petits
haut-parleurs de 2 x 2 watts ce pas
ignorants mais ça fonctionne côté
performances ça va bien marcher ça va
dépendre une fois de plus de la config
que vous allez prendre entre intel core
i5 i7 enough
très honnêtement si vous avez de la
bureautique i7 ça parfaitement bien 9 si
vous voulez aller faire du montage vidéo
mettez la ram 32 gigas ne sera
parfaitement ménard hier dès lors vous
les faire céder la route ou jeux vidéos
avec beaucoup de calme c'est pareil
prévoyez ça monte en puissance
c'est pareil quand vous achetez un
ordinateur vers un net recul plus loin
projetez vous dans quelques années ça
vous est de garder quelques bonnes
années quand même donc regarder
aujourd'hui à 2 ans à 5 ans là où vous
pensez pouvoir aller est ce que vous
avez besoin d'un peu plus de ressources
de logiciels qui sont pas bleus manquent
le plus gourmand en ce moment là donc
n'hésitez pas dès lors vous allez
investir là dedans à prendre une config
un peu plus boosté pour prévoir à
l'avenir assis à côté de ça vous pensez
vous aller uniquement relais des séries
faire un peu de bureautique mais pas à
puce
un i7 sera parfaitement bien pour les
années à venir les cinq jours un petit
peu limite limite mais il cède pour moi
c'est parfaitement bien à côté de ça je
choisis bien votre config aura 8 16 32
gigas de ram c'est de la ddr4 ça marche
bien votre stockage réfléchit c'est
aussi penser vraiment à ceux dont vous
allez avoir besoin venir est-ce que vous
avez des choses qui vont être gourmande
en stockage oui non ou pas ou peut-être
dites vous bien fréquents connectique
nos ventes par exemple quelques instants
vous allez pouvoir brancher on m'appelle
un disque dur externe au cloud est
tranquille après c'est une machine
qu'une fois qu'elle tourne va bien en
termes de refroidissement ça marche et à
une bonne répartition de la chaire dont
vous serez absolument pas embêtés là
dessus on faisait vraiment tranquille il
très belle maîtrise de la part de dell
sans cet xps 15 donc ça ça roule
l'autonomie est excellente et derrière
du 97 water ça marche parfaitement bien
non vous êtes con qu'il peut cependant
pour poser tranquillement se recharge
rapide mais en plus notre faim charger
un petit peu sympa mais vous venez
l'enroulé comme ça vous avez votre cas
vous disposez se sentent proches de
pratique bon du point de vue de
l'autonomie c'est pareil ce n'est pas
vous poser de questions fait une machine
qui marche extrêmement bien le clavier
pas malheur moi j'ai une version qwerty
vous aurez une version azerty soyez
tranquilles il ya une course qui est un
peu longue mais il ya un bon retour de
touche moi j'aime bien ce qu'il est
plutôt bien c'est pratique on trouve
très bien les touches le pavé tactile
est aussi plutôt pas mal bon ça c'est un
grand classique s'annonce bien ses
standards
d'où ce point de vue là y'a pas grand
chose à dire j'aimerais bien maintenant
j'utilise un macbook pro 15 n'avoir
contacté par un peu plus grands un peu
plus large et un peu de jeunes qui
pourraient utiliser là ça pourrait avoir
recensé paquet amélioré cette année mais
je vous en ai déjà parlé c'est le fait
de venir intégrer la webcam ici et non
pas en bas c'est évident et de filmer un
petit peu füle né comme ça c'est un peu
plus disgracieux là c'est bien si bien
intégré il ya un beau travail de r&d qui
a été fait de la part de dell là dessus
donc ça c'est bien idéalement placé
après on pourrait regretter ce n'est que
du 720p
on n'est pas en full hd me bon c'est de
la petite webcam c'est pour de la vidéo
compte si toutefois vous voulez une
meilleure qualité vous allez vous
prendre une webcam extérieur logitech ou
compagnie la connectique est cool ici
vous avez votre petit port pendant leur
chang'e 2
des trois points ça marche du hdmi 2.0
ça marche votre porte son nom dans mol 3
une prise jack 3.5 qui sert aussi bien
de micro que deux cas ça c'est cool et
d'un côté vous avez un autre port usb 3
points et un port de carte sd
ça c'est bien ça soit vraiment vraiment
bien retrouve de moins en moins mais
pour tous les vidéastes et pour tous les
photographes croyez-moi ça ça peut avoir
son importance on va donc retrouver un
peu la logique que faisait tout à
l'heure à savoir que si vous faites de
la photo ou de la vidéo pour moi c'est
une bécane qui est vraiment optimisé ne
serait ce que par ce petit port qui
conservait sa montre choix stratégiques
qui mis en place en tout cas de la part
de dell parce que concerner un port
comme ça ça coûte de l'argent il ya
beaucoup de fabricants aujourd'hui qui
met que des ports usb c'est débrouillez
vous avec 2 d'après donc ça c'est bien
sûr ça plutôt intéressant tout cas bravo
d'elle on a du bluetooth 5.0 du wifi six
mois si vous comprenez bien sûr une
telle que j'aime bien il tourne sur
windows dix familles c'est un ordinateur
que j'aime beaucoup que je trouve bien
que je trouve performant que je trouve
endurant j'adore les tran avec le hall
est comme ça si on est dans une phase
d'acquisitions sur ce produit on dit et
ce qu'il est bien réfléchie c'est
vraiment je vous dis une fois de plus
sur un ordinateur comme ça avoue usage
futur
réfléchissez à vos besoins actuels si
vous voulez vraiment du multimédia le
top de multimédia pour moi l'écran oled
et je dirais pas quasiment indispensable
et c'est ce qui se fait mieux c'est plus
beau non vraiment ça c'est vraiment top
qui sera un peu moins énergivore qu'une
dali ps
moi j'aime beaucoup cela bien sûr des
toits qui est vraiment maîtrisé qui est
très beau et les trucs que je verrai en
tout cas en évolution potentielle à
l'avenir ça serait un tractage un peu
plus grands venir gagner un petit peu
utilisé cette place un petit peu morte
sur les côtés pour gagner un peu en
dimensions et puis venir légèrement
retravaillé un peu le design pour le
rendre un poil plus sexy c'est un design
qui est très bien qui marche bien et un
petit peu conventionnel aujourd'hui chez
dell pour la gamme xps mais qui fait la
sphère donc voila moi ton sac ou en tout
cas si vous intéresse vous aimez bien
évidemment en lien en bas en description
si vous voulez acheter un bon produit
endurant de bonne qualité avec un
produit de la gamme xps de dell vous
serez absolument pas déçu et j'aime
beaucoup cette version avec l'écran oled
dix neuf voilà vous me dire ce que vous
en pensez en commentaire vous invite à
aller voir la chaîne de mon pote arnaud
comme je le dis vous avez le lien en bas
dans la description et puis que tu
ailles on se retrouve très rapidement
avec une grosse actu plein de choses
donc ça c'est cool vous embrasse
à bientôt